good morning everyone thanks for joining
us in this workshop on proud cloud and
the future of work my name is Miss moon
Anousheh I am a researcher in Microsoft
Research AI and today I'm coordinating
this workshop together with vani who is
director of data science in Microsoft
Research outreach and for today we have
put together an agenda of six exciting
talks all centered around the topic of
large-scale crowdsourcing and citizen
science initiatives and before I we move
on with the agenda I'd like to spend a
few minutes trying to frame a little bit
the conversation for today and even the
breakout session maybe a little bit
later on so crowdsourcing research in
citizen science is now at least 10 years
old in fact the first human computation
workshop happened in 2009 hosted by kdd
back then in Paris and in this last 10
years we have seen at least a few
initiatives that have been successful in
creating large-scale projects either for
unpaid crowd sourcing like citizen
science or others and in fact ante we're
going to be lucky to hear updates from
some of the most representative ones in
the field today like the human
computation Institute suniverse and
brain life but what I wanted to point
out as well is that usually around this
project large projects there is an
extended landscape that supports the
development of these projects and I
would like to touch upon that so of
course in the last few years we have
seen a lot of effort going into building
platforms for citizen science and the
top two challenges in the space of
building infrastructure infrastructure
that supports collaboration have been to
design good incentive schemes for having
workers to provide high quality work now
from a research point of view it might
seem like these are problems of the past
it might seem like we have solved all
these all these problems in conferences
and pay
purrs but the truth is that there remain
challenges today in practice and they
can become important factors that define
whether the life of a crowdsourcing
project is going to be long or not and
which is why I wanted to bring them back
today so that we can hear more about
what these challenges look like in
practice
next eventually the data that is
collected with this crowd sourcing
platforms is being used to eventually
train a machine learning model and the
long term topic of discussion in both
the machine learning and the crowd
sourcing community has been how can we
actually train machine learning models
with imperfect human input and beyond
that we would also like to have these
machine learning models to be put back
into the crowd sourcing frameworks in
order to reduce the cost and the effort
of crowdsourcing and while again we have
discussed this multiple times on how to
build high persistence and
human-in-the-loop systems these
techniques of putting back the machine
learning models in a way that they can
reduce the cost of crowdsourcing have
just started to to be used in practice
and next obviously the long-term goal of
building all these models is to have
them assist the experts in the
decision-making or even help the
scientists in pushing forward the
boundaries of scientific research and in
this space I call it under construction
and it is under construction because we
still do not understand very well what
are the properties of a good machine
learning collaborator what does it even
mean for a human to work in this
environment working with one or many
machine learning models and to
understand what is the role of the human
and how can the human make sense of all
the signals and moreover we want experts
to be introduced and to be fused into
the crowdsourcing framework so that they
can give feedback to the data collection
process so that the data collection
process can be reshaped in a way that
the models that we are going to train in
the future can actually be
helpful to experts in the
decision-making so I'll leave it to this
picture I hope I'll hear more about
these questions during the talks and
during the the breakout and we're going
to move on with our agenda the first
speaker is a Jacob and LJ is a principal
researcher in the adaptive systems and
interaction group and she's going to
talk about how can we enable AI
development with human intelligence
thank you
good morning everyone let me tell you a
little bit about myself I did my PhD
like years ago at the intersection of AI
and humans thinking about how AI and
humans could call a braid on complex
tasks then I when I joined MSR like nine
years ago it was kind of the time that
crafts were saying human computation was
just being discovered through platforms
like Amazon Mechanical Turk citizen
science and I kind of find myself so
excited about this large-scale scalable
access to human intelligence on these
platforms and over the years we've
looked into so many different problems
in the space with our collaborators like
Lucy from galaxy zoos the universe and
others uhr as our own platform at
Microsoft thinking about how to make
crowdsourcing high-quality how to get
people working on crowdsourcing engaged
and so many different problems today for
today though I really want to think
about the role of humans in particularly
the crowd in the development of machine
learning systems I'm gonna kind of take
that perspective because this is a very
rich space and I could give many
different talks today I kind of just
pick that perspective for today just
thinking about like we always think
about machine learning platforms is this
very data-centric kind of mechanical
process for building systems but is it
really that way and what kind of
algorithmic and workflow style
innovations we can do in that space to
make it better
so you've seen this kind of slice at
every AI talk there has been a lot of
advances mainly in perception tasks Tom
getting into the language for many tasks
but you're also seeing that existing AI
algorithms fail in different ways fail
in unexpected ways sometimes they fail
correspond to problems that we have in
the society corresponding to disparate
impact for different genders ages races
and so forth sometimes they lead to
reliability issues for example when a
self-driving car or a physical robot
fails in the world
and a lot of the time I spend these days
is really thinking about these kind of
reliability bias problems and thinking
about ways to overcome them and I really
think that if you try to uncover the
pipelines and workflows for developing
AI systems and just look into them
really try to understand what happens at
every step of the development workflow
that gives us good clues about how we
can improve this process in different
ways so that we can lead to more
reliable AI development so what I mean
by that when you ask Commission learning
researcher about how they are building a
system they are gonna give a vert load
that's very similar to the one on the
top
they are gonna say okay I have this
beautiful data set somebody has
collected this for me or for something
or that's available on the internet so
I'm just gonna focus on that because
that's readily available I'm gonna get
that find a problem that works well for
that dataset so it kind of works the
opposite way he would really like to
know the problem and then collect the
data most of the time it happens the
other way and then they divide the data
it says this is my training data this is
my test data really focus on the
algorithmic innovations on like how many
layers of the deep neural network it's
gonna be and how the parameters are
gonna be and how the drop part is gonna
be and so forth and then they get this
really beautiful model very
sophisticated test it on the test data
that comes from the same distribution as
a training data evaluate it look at the
aggregate number like an accuracy say
score I've done great my numbers look
better than your numbers this is a great
system however real-world deployments of
AI systems look quite different than
that right our workflows are very
different first of all this training
data doesn't really come from sky
actually on some surveys that pays Mira
has been involved in as well in our
department we actually see that 90
percent of people's time go in in real
deployment scenarios go to tasks that
are not about model training it goes to
data collection data cleaning
debugging the models and software so
this step of training is a big step in
making our machine learning models work
and there is of course the data in most
cases come from humans sometime from
crowdsourcing sometime from user data
then we have a lot of human involvement
actually in the develop development
stage a human decides what the objective
function is gonna be a human is gonna
decide what the interaction is gonna be
and the human is going to be deciding
how to evaluate the system which is the
safety criteria which is the reliable to
care area which is the biosecurity area
and of course then when we push these
models into the world in particular if
there are reliability problems it is
better to have humans involved to watch
over these systems and correct them when
they are making mistakes and not finally
we really want to watch these systems
all the time and see where they are
failing and get through this continuous
feedback loop and improvement loop and
of course a lot of engineering and data
science people are involved in that
process very heavily so it's actually
misleading to think about the mission
learning pipeline is the one and only
about where we only focus on the
algorithms but you have to acknowledge
that people and many different types of
people including the crowd including the
developers including the data scientists
and users are actually part of this
development loop so today in this talk I
really picked a few projects we didn't
we've done over the years where we are
touching different points in this
workflow and show how we can have
algorithmic workflow innovations in some
sense to actually make that process
better and just to show examples of what
kind of work we can do in that space and
then I'm gonna finish up with some
things that is top of mind right now for
me in terms of thinking about these
workflows and the crowding moment so
this is a slide from 2001 so a lot has
changed since then but I think the
common trend is those days the fact is
that we're gonna celebrate algorithms
but to get algorithms work very well we
really need a lot of data and this is
more true today than ever with
large-scale deep neural networks that
are really really data hungry so
actually
in the latest celebration of AI actually
the hidden hero has been crowdsourcing
workers they have done all of the work
that enabled that with the cocoa dataset
with the image nets with the large-scale
data sets we are collecting from the
internet today so it is really important
to acknowledge you know the human effort
that went into making these machine
learning models really successful in the
last decade or so one thing we have
looked into I think this is where we
started in 2012 was thinking about label
collection and crowdsourcing which is a
core task when you're in doing image
datasets language datasets anything like
that I really think about given that
there's gonna be a big demand for human
input to construct these large-scale
data sets how can we make this process
more efficient so that we can be more
respectful for the human time and this
also is a big concern for instance I
flat citizen science platform like Zoo
universe collects a zoo so this is why
we collaborated with them on this
project back then because for them the
amount of students science is really
determined how much data is going to be
collected for science which is going to
be determining how much insights and
innovations are going to be found for
astronomers right so in this problem
what really happens is that we have a
test coming again we can use machine
learning algorithms to generate initial
hypotheses about what the label is going
to be this task is quite simple this is
the original Galaxy Zoo you have an
image of the galaxy and you're trying to
classify this image into six different
classes of course the machine analysis
on this task is going to be just the
weak evidence for what the true label is
going to be so you want to query
multiple people but each person in a
paid crowdsourcing setting may cost
money instead in science it's gonna cost
peoples times right you want to be
careful about that and there are some
questions that we looked into into this
project how do we fuse automated
analysis with human input so that we can
get a lot of the work done with machine
learning can we learn which thisone
scientists are more accurate
for which tasks so that we can put more
emphasis on to the into their answers
and get to the true answer more
accurately more quickly and can we do
retirements because this was the biggest
problem they were they were facing I
think still it's a big problem for the
platform's you really don't want to put
30 people on every single task because
maybe some things aren't quite easy or
some things are unsolvable which is also
a case in here so this is when we build
the crafting system where we had this
workflow that combines multiple machine
learning models with a decision tree
attic planner that worked in synchrony
the machine learning models learned
about the tasks task characteristics
which tasks are hard which tasks are
easy also learned about the citizen
scientist which one are better at what
task and then all of these inferences
including the Machine inference about
the task went to a planner where the
planner the decision to take analysis at
every step and ask the question of if I
got one more citizen scientist into this
problem with my answer change and with
this we actually show that we could get
the accuracy of the original system by
only spending half of the human
resources there is actually this
doubling of the efficiency that we could
see with this platform so I think a lot
of these ideas are still pretty valid
for the crowdsourcing systems we have
today and some of these ideas were then
actually implemented in our internal
platform UHS those were the case for the
objective labeling problems there is a
galaxy there is a gram to a tensor
hopefully you assume that it exists that
we are trying to give to the astronomer
but then when we were working with
different product groups we realize that
in a lot of cases the tasks are
subjective a lot of the community kind
of assume that there is this one ground
truth answer that is true for all humans
but actually for many labeling tasks
like for example relevance judgments in
being we saw that that wasn't the case
even for something like this like you
have a bunch of images and you're trying
to classify whether it's a cat picture
or not if
favorite problem for AI world right
people when you get into the instances
you could actually have a lot of
subjectivity is a cartoon cat a cat is a
cat machine like this work machines is
that a cat so when we get into the
nuances of the data set we realized that
people were writing like 50 page
instructions for four crowd workers just
to kind of convey their idea of what a
cat is and it was becoming a really
cumbersome process for workers because
people had to look into the data to
create all of these like okay I guess
the cartoon cat is a cat a picture of a
cat is a cat but the Mishi that the work
machine is that I can write it was it
was very cumbersome but it was also
really bad for workers because workers
were doing an honest job
but then if the instructions miss
something they were being penalized for
giving the wrong answer however a
difference really giving the wrong
answer so beside maybe we should just
look into this process completely
differently and this is how this is when
we did revolt this is called is called
in collaboration with Salima mercy so
what he said is that look let's change
the way we do crowdsourcing let's make
it interactive let's get the crowd
really talk about what they are saying
maybe through that we can actually
enable these rich data structures that
can really capture the uncertainty that
exists in data and then we can really
show that uncertainty to the requesters
and they can decide what to do with that
data
so that's what reward came out to be we
get unlabeled data and we got we get
through an interactive crowdsourcing
process now and we built through the
years two sets that enable this kind of
interaction with the crowd workers with
the cog wall project and so forth so in
the first step crowd workers label the
instances and if there isn't
disagreement they explained why they
thought the answer should be a or b and
then we use other crowd workers to look
into this rich data now with crowd
explanations and build clusters start
categorizing them
and what we ended up is actually this
rich data structure where people could
see clusters for cartoon cats and
clusters for pictures of cats and
clusters for for other things and then
this data actually then became reusable
for different purposes because somebody
who wants to train a classifier for live
cats could come and select some of the
instances as positive and some of the
instances as negative and somebody may
come and drew a different decision
boundary and train a classifier a tree
in a different classifier so the data
set actually became reusable so what we
showed with this work is that when you
put interaction into crowdsourcing and
enable the collection of more
sophisticated responses rather than
labels you could actually require the
dropped requirement on requesters to
create these 50-page guidelines it
became better for workers because they
weren't penalized for giving the wrong
answers uncertain answers and you could
capture this restructure that damn late
later can be used for different purposes
including debugging where the models
fail and then we said okay let's get a
real-world AI system and think about how
we can use the crowd to complement the
system during execution not in training
but in execution interaction with real
people and see how this crowd enrollment
can be good for addressing some of the
reliability problems so we looked into
the image captioning system which I
which was actually a well celebrated AI
challenge in the community where
existing papers show that these systems
got so better that they were better than
humans and all of that and we wanted to
see whether that was really the case and
how human hub can be useful to help
people when they were using this these
systems which actually exist today at
Microsoft as the caption bar and we've
done experiments where we showed and
this was these were experiments were
done with blind people because when you
read a lot of these papers you actually
see that they provide the assistance of
the blind
as the motivating scenarios we wanted to
see how much value they were really
getting out of it and what we showed was
that for blind users just giving the
system to people was actually really bad
like too terrible satisfaction and you
can't see this from this picture here
this is a time to beat that says it's
it's basically people really upset about
the crash and the caption given for this
picture automatically was a man sitting
on a table which will didn't have but
that man you brought people in in
different ways either correcting it with
an offline task or getting into a
dialogue with the caption body you could
see the performers going up and people
are really getting a satisfactory
experience and then later we can use
that human data to improve our systems
or generate some templates that can be
used across different people for a
battered kept for a better improved
caption the last thing I want to mention
is the work we've been doing on
troubleshooting and debugging of AI this
is another area where we can use crowd
input to really inform our models in
terms of how they can get better so this
is actually the work that bass minissha
has been leading on troubleshooting
debugging we did a demo of a simpler
system yesterday that we are working
with product groups with but on a
research side we've been looking into
using the crowd for debugging of
integrative systems that are composed of
multiple components and before as an
engineering team you decide where I
wanna invest my efforts you could
actually use the crowd to simulate
different improvement approaches team
has come up with to simulate what the
performance would be once you invested
into these improvements and get graphs
like this where you could really
speculate like okay I have this
intuitive system with three components
let's say where should I spend my
improvement effort how much improvement
in the final system output I would get
if I improve the visual detector the
language model or capture ear anchor or
all of them or even simulate DIF fix
ideas on that so just finishing up with
some next steps up on problems at least
for me in
space we really want to think about how
we can use humans to understand deeper
problems in machine learning models
getting into biases getting into blind
spots this is something we've been
investing time into but I think this is
an important space as we are building
these machine learning models that are
going to be important for many
real-world tasks like half and other
domains we really need human help in
understanding where they are failing or
how they can get better I think they're
the cloud platforms provide a beautiful
platform to understand about human
judgments how humans make decisions kind
of they can provide the lens for us to
really analyze a human side of things as
well and Andy has been doing she's not
here anymore but she's vicious she's
doing a lot of work in that space
understanding human biases through
crowdsourcing and she can tell you more
about that one step that I'm I didn't
talk about today is that in the
developments of systems we have humans
providing value judgments thinking about
the ideal behavior of the system we see
a lot of discussions about this and
self-driving cars and so forth like you
know there is the moral machine kind of
ideas but I think when we get into the
engineering pipelines thinking about how
we are going to be deciding what these
systems ought to do is a big task and
then there is actually a lot of issues
around ethical ethical side of data
collection we see that this when we are
doing data collection for accessibility
is it fine to grab data from the
internet what does consent mean when we
are doing data collection and so forth
so again it reads space of problems so
I'll stop there and if you have any
questions if I time left I can do that
or we can talk during the day let's take
one question while we set up Corey yes
I need to turn turn it on okay so it's
really great overview of a lot of really
interesting work so thank you come and
talk to me if you want to hear any more
about it yeah okay okay yeah the one
thing that really piqued my interest is
this idea of kind of inserting humans
into the pipeline at different places
where you're trying to decide where do
we where do we place our efforts to
improve the pipeline using an automated
approach and so it occurs to me that you
might identify in the course of doing
that that there are certain areas that
could have the greatest impact on the
other hand there's another dimension of
that which is that each one of those
places in the pipeline has a different
sort of level of challenge associated
with achieving that kind of capability
in an AI so I'm wondering you know how
do you do that kind of assessment in
order to be able to then decide what the
cost-benefit analysis is that's a great
question I don't think we have the level
of maturity of understanding in this
space to really do that right now
the fact is also that in terms of those
human involvements the actors could be
different so you could do some things
with the crowd but for some things you
may need the developer time for some
things you may need to bring in an
ethicist to really answer questions
about the value judgments and the
availability of these resources may also
be different so I think one one way
we're thinking about this is really
trying to build tools to give to people
as they are building the AI systems I
think we are really early on that but we
have been doing bits of work here and
there so that people who are building
these systems can decide okay at least I
have the tools to do it then you can
reason about but how what is the scale
you want to do it when you want to do it
with how many people you want to do it
thank you
thank you that was really interesting I
have a question on the cultural aspect
if there are studies which involve some
cultural aspect what amis like when you
look at the data on the web is very
multilingual and so more probably
because people come from different
cultures right we come from different
countries and we still use English and
so I'm wondering when people label if
the cultural aspect may have some impact
you know for instance I see a picture
somebody could say this is an emotional
hug and somebody else would say I don't
know something else right
stiff-upper-lip I don't know something
there Studies on that but that's a great
point and that's actually one of the
motivating things for us to focus on the
subjectivity and kind of collecting rich
data and not limit crowdsourcing to this
label aggregation world where there is
one truth and we only try to seek that
one truth but we actually acknowledge
that people have different opinions and
we can get them talking and providing
that complex data and then we have we
develop methods to make sense of that
data but I think overall there is
another question I'm really thinking a
lot these days about which is as we are
putting more AI into people's work for
example like ai writing sentences for
people ai writing captions for
journalists ai doing all of these things
we know that these systems are really
good at learning major patterns but they
don't really capture the diversity we
have in our world like the diversity of
different cultures diversity of
different perspectives so are there
things we are gonna lose if we just let
AI to do a lot of these things about
capturing our beautiful diversity and I
think that's why I really want to focus
on these hybrid workflows where we can't
really capture the human you know
perspective but have AI kind of helping
with maybe the boring part or the the
part that doesn't really require that
human in journey in you know human
intelligence so a lot of work to be done
in that space I think thank you so next
we're gonna have Corey Inkpen talk about
a human area complementarity Mike okay
I'm really excited to be here today just
like a chase started out I'll give you a
little bit of my background so I spent
10 years researching face to face
collaboration looking at tabletop
displays wall displays things like that
in academia as a professor then when I
came to Microsoft I spent 10
approximately 10 years looking at
distributed collaboration connecting
people over a distance using video and
now recently I am starting to look at
another form of collaboration so this
time looking at human AI collaboration
so this is a new thread of research for
me I'm really excited about it and love
to make new connections in this space so
today I'm going to share some of the my
early thoughts on human AI complement
the arity a lot of the things we're
talking about I worked very closely with
H a and basa and I have some rock star
interns and an AI resident so a lot of
the things that the ideas that I'm
sharing here are things that we've all
sort of been brainstorming and talking
about together so one of the things that
we've been talking a lot this summer
about is is the best AI really the best
AI so if I'm building an AI system to be
run autonomously or to do the tasks
completely then yes I probably want to
maximize the accuracy or the f1 score of
that AI but if that AI is going to be
deployed into a workflow that has humans
do I really want to be maximizing the
accuracy but I want it to be doing the
same tasks as the human maybe we need to
dig a little more deeply and look
actually at the workflow of the task
to decide what are the best things that
maybe the AI should do and what are ways
that it can complement the human so
that's one of the things that that we
are starting to look at this summer and
so we're thinking about complementary
abilities and they're gonna give you a
couple examples here so let's assume
that I am a lab technician and I'm
really good at identifying whether a
cell is cancerous and I'm very accurate
at this so I have high accuracy on this
but I do so many scans in a day that I
missed some along the way
so my recall is a little bit lower in
that case maybe we should be looking at
building an AI that actually makes sure
that it shows me all the potential
places I should be looking so that I
don't miss any so we might want to
optimize the AI for recall so now if I
take a different hat and I'm now some
sort of astronomer and I'm really good
at detecting flashing lights in the sky
so my recall is really great I never
missed one but I have a trouble deciding
well is that some sort of meteor is it
an airplane flying by I'm not very good
at that so maybe my AI needs to be
optimized for precision for those types
of tasks
so those are two toya examples but it
shows you that how you want to build
your AI to work with the human depends a
lot on the task and on the context
okay I'll go with the old-fashioned way
or my computer is not working
Oh Oh it was just stuck okay now I want
to give an example of non complimentary
or non collaborative and we see in the
news all the time
examples of AI being deployed in the
real world and this was one from a year
ago and and so the ice immigration
system has a risk assessment software
they enter information for the the
people that they find and the system is
supposed to give you a recommendation as
to whether you should detain that person
or release them so it gives a risk
factor well in a changing political
climate a year ago it was reported that
this algorithmic system still is in
place was still being used but it has
one decision it always says detained and
so this is an example where a having a
system doesn't even make sense and it
doesn't it all work with the human now
the news article goes on to say but the
human can override it anytime they want
although I'm not sure how often the ice
official is actually going to override
override the system so that example is
is to lead into this idea the the
examples that gave you before about the
the cancer cells or the Astronomy
problem dealt with complementary in
terms of performance but it's a lot more
than just what am I good at and what am
i weak at it's also what are the the the
human factors that influence how well
the system gets used do I trust it do I
believe in it how accountable mi if I'm
a judge or a doctor I may feel perfectly
comfortable ignoring the system in the
recommendation it gives me if I'm a lab
tech maybe not so it depends on my role
it depends how much authority I have it
depends even the instructions that the
system gives me is going to influence
how I feel about it and how I engage and
interact with it and there's a whole
host of questions here that are still
completely open research questions like
we
don't fully understand how to deploy
these systems into the real world and
and for people to be able to engage with
them so this is a graphic I like to show
of this space that that I'm really
interested in working in so I'm
obviously interested in human AI
collaboration but I'm interested in
these complex problems where the AI
knows a part of the world and it has it
has a status set and it can learn
complex patterns within it but the human
knows a part of the world as well and
it's slightly different so we overlap we
might know the same data that goes in
but I think human don't understand the
complexity of the model but I know other
things about the world and I have other
experiences that I rely on and so truly
we want to have these two systems work
together the other thing is I also want
this to be evolving over time as these
things get deployed we need to have a
feedback loop in here we need to ensure
that the AI is always is continually
evolving to get better and the human is
always evolving to get better if I
override the system and and and feel
that it's I'm not I don't trust it for
that particular instance I should know
at some point down the road whether or
not that was the right decision or not
or I should be able to learn from that
because ultimately we want to grow these
two circles to encompass more of the
world so another sub theme within this
that I'm really fascinating about is
this idea I call designing for
disagreement and again a lot of the
examples I'm giving are related to sort
of human decision-making so if I'm
working with the AI together and we sort
of come up with the same answer great
but what if we don't
what if we're doing something and and
the the AI believe something different
than than what I believe and I think
that's a really interesting space
because that's where a lot of these
human factors come into play
do I trust it do I feel that I have
authority to overrule it how do I
resolve this disagreement so there's a
few things that we've been exploring and
the data set that that we started to
look at was this recidivism data set a
recidivism is a prediction as to whether
a person will commit a crime in the next
two years so there was a student at
Dartmouth that had done a crowdsourcing
study where they had Mechanical Turk
workers predict recidivism for a
population of defendants and they
compared that the risk predictions of
the Turkish with compass the commercial
AI system and so that was the data set
that we started for this exploration and
just so you have a sense of what the the
Mechanical Turk task was they got a
little paragraph about the defendant see
not very much but all the the features
are in there it in some runnings of the
experiment it gave the race and in other
ones that didn't and then they had to
say yes or no and they had to do 50 of
these trials and then they got a score
at the end so this research got a lot of
publicity at the time because all the
reports said hey guess what humans are
just as good as the AI system because
they both were approximately 65%
accurate well our research question was
are they coming up with the same 65
percent or is it different because if
it's different then I can leverage the
complementarity I can leverage what the
algorithm is good at and I can leverage
what the human is good at and so when we
looked at it this was the pie chart we
saw not only from the darkness study but
in our rerunning zuv it it essentially
comes back very similar to this 50% of
the time compass the algorithmic system
and the Turkish agree and have the
correct answer according to the ground
truth in the data set the other half of
the pie is split pretty evenly into
thirds one-third of the time the
algorithm is correct and the human is
wrong another third the human is correct
and they
is wrong and the last third they agree
but they're both wrong so we're gonna
ignore the purple they're both wrong for
now but if I can find a way to leverage
again the strengths of the algorithm and
the human I should be able to increase
this to be about 80% been quite solved
it yet
the first approach was to try to build a
hybrid bottle let's see if we can build
a model that tells us in this particular
instance take the human decision in this
particular instance take the AI decision
we got slight improvements but it could
also be within the noise I think the
fact that it was a Mechanical Turk data
set is influencing this
I won't dive into I still believe this
is possible
it just isn't isn't quite showing here
another and there's a lot of work in the
community I can give an explanation of
the model to the user to help them
understand did I miss something or is
that or is the algorithm missing
something another variant on this and
and I'm sure it was presented during the
faculty summit is you could look at an
error analysis and Basin H a have have a
tool that they've been looking at this
so I can see where does the model make
mistakes and does that help me
understand whether or not I should I
should utilize it here and then we would
like to get more complex with this and
enable even richer interactions how can
I engage with the model similar to a
would with an expert human ok if I was
dealing with an expert they would they
wouldn't just come in and say yes or no
they would tell me why or we would have
a dialogue about it or we would have
some sort of exchange and so I think we
need to get to this point to really be
able to to interact well so to wrap up
super passionate about human plus a ki
collaboration but the plus isn't enough
there's lots of research that's actually
starting to show if you just try to glue
these two systems together you can
actually make them worse so we do need
to think about this complementarity how
they're gonna work together and what's
going to make them the most successful
Thanks
I so you mentioned that the data set
that was built by the Turkish there was
some potential issues with that could
you if you remember the the Venn diagram
where I'm interested in problems where
the human has access to additional
information then the model does when we
use the Turkish we tell them these are
the exact same features that the model
has so there's very little difference in
the amount of information they have I my
hypothesis is is if we were to run this
with judges there would be a lot more
information they would be relying on
which could make it better in terms of
complementarity it also might make it
worse because there's bias etc so within
the turk dataset it was just that they
had the exact same features that the
model had okay good so so so you said
you might give it to judges and it would
be different but what if you gave it to
non experts but with more information
would you see also a difference yes
we've been looking for datasets to be
able to to do that again the qualitative
data things that is hard for the for the
algorithm to understand but a human
might be able to make sense of it and it
might provide information I do think
even non experts would benefit from that
the other piece that we've done related
to that and carry in the back has been
running this is we took that task and we
added a photo and this was to look at
racial bias so the hypothesis was that
little word related to the text doesn't
have a lot of salience II maybe if we
show them a picture of a defendant it'll
influence and it did it influenced it in
an opposite way than we expected so for
white defendants it made no difference
whether we showed the photo or not for
black defendants that did make a
difference and they were less likely to
predict that they would commit a crime
in the future
I have a couple hypotheses for why that
is the case I mean it could be that
people are trying to be conscious of
their biases it could be that the photos
we use were not real photos of the
defendants they were they were from a
generic face data set and it could be
that the Delta between the photo for
certain to fit my image of what a
defendant of this race is it could be
further away from the photos or the
photos could be balancing it out some we
don't know exactly why but we've had
multiple runnings of it and this trend
continues to happen that we get this
benefit from show from humanizing it
from showing the photo for the black
defendants so some aspects of what
humans do in their work day and life
clearly they're no good at and others
they're much better
some of the tasks they I can do maybe
should do are the one that we are worse
than so are you thinking about that
pompona
like what we know from psychology and
cognition about what humans very good
yes I think that's a big part of the
complementarity what what are what is
the AI good at and what should we have
it do another question and I'm not a
machine learning researcher is if I'm
interacting with the system a lot can it
start to learn what I'm good at versus
what you're good at and so that the
tasks against segments in a way so that
we're maximizing our expertise we may be
able to utilize systems in that way as
well Thank You Corey um so next we have
Donna Girardi who is going to give a
presentation on her work on how to
recognize when a crowd will offer a
different answer for visual questions
Donna has done a lot of work and
recently also we're collaborating with
Microsoft
search on better understanding how to
build vision models for people with
disabilities and looking forward to your
talk done thank you
can everyone hear me okay okay great
so thank you for being here today I'm
going to talk about the task of visual
question answering so shown on the slide
are four examples of visual questions
which are simply questions about images
and the goal is to find the answer to
each question so why should we care
about visual question answering these
were examples highlight questions asked
by both sighted and blind people so as
an example a person who is blind may
want to know when preparing food what
food to eat when what is the flavor of
food when considering what to eat or a
marketing professional may want to know
how sighted people's reactions are to an
image such as does this picture look
scary so what's been doing so far in
this problem of trying to answer visual
questions we have seen work come out
both in terms of human powered systems
that are being used today largely by
people who are blind and there's also
been quite a bit of effort in the
research community from the machine
learning people trying to figure out how
to design automated systems and just to
highlight one of the first systems that
came out called vizwiz in this popular
system that was used between 2011 and
2015 it was reportedly used by over a
hundred thousand it was probably used to
ask over a hundred thousand visual
questions and typically three answers
per fishel question were collected from
the crowd so here I'm showing ten
answers for each visual question that we
were collecting from 10 unique crowd
workers on Amazon Mechanical Turk and
now our work is inspired by two key
observations about these answers the
first observation is that different
people can all arrive at the same answer
so for example all ten people agreed
about the question is my monitor on that
the answer is yes in such cases where
the crowd agrees time money is wasted on
trying to collect redundant answers
the second key observation is that a
single answer may be insufficient to
answer the visual question because the
crowd can offer different answers for
example the question which side of the
room is the toilet on is ambiguous some
people say it is on the right likely
because the toilet is positioned in the
right side of the image others say it is
on the left perhaps because they imagine
standing in the room and seeing the
toilet on their left side and yet
another perspective is that the toilet
is in the middle of the room for such
cases it's not necessarily fairly clear
how systems and how in general we should
respond to such answer differences and
so the goal of the work that I'm going
to discuss today is thinking about how
do we efficiently collect all plausible
answers so I'm gonna talk about two ways
that we have considered in my research
group the first is based on the idea of
learning to anticipate when a crowd will
answer a visual question differently in
order to more efficiently capture all
possible answers for a batch of visual
questions and then the second is
learning to anticipate why a crowd will
answer a visual question differently
towards helping users resolve answer
differences so diving into the first one
our first approach again is inspired by
the observation that crowd answers can
match or differ and so the premise of
this work is that redundancy in some
cases is wasteful and in some cases is
valuable so our analysis that motivated
this work is based on looking at ten
answers per visual question for nearly
500,000 visual questions included were
images from the business data set which
shows visual questions asked by blind
users so these visual questions often
address accessibility issues for daily
lives we also examined a dataset that
was asked by sighted users about
high-quality images collected from the
internet and finally we also considered
images that were asked by sighted users
about abstract scenes so this shows here
the agree
trends across the three datasets we
looked at to motivate the work in total
we analyzed nearly 5 million
crowd-sourced answers and we found that
across the three datasets that the crowd
agree for about 47% so in the answers
are differing about half the time okay
so in absolute terms across all this
data this means that nearly $12,000 in
over four years of 40-hour work weeks
were spent to collect redundant answers
on the half of visual on the 50% of the
visual questions where one answer was
enough so the idea the first piece of
work is we want to be able to predict if
a crowds answers will disagree or will
match or differ and so we went ahead and
did this idea the first step of course
is we collected a bunch of data where we
had an image a question and a label for
each example next step of course is to
separate a part to create training data
which then is fed to the algorithm we
explored two different flavors of
algorithms one was a deep learning
algorithm one is the random forest
algorithm with handcrafted features and
then see how well it does on novel cases
that it was not trained on so given the
black box we trained apply it to new
examples get out the answer predictions
as well as the algorithms confidence in
those answer predictions okay and so we
look to see how well can this work in
practice can we figure out whether or
not a crowd will agree and so if we just
look at the baseline the best we can do
today which is given an image and a
question randomly guess we see that
that's kind of the baseline performance
across two data sets we studied we look
at what happens when we look at an
algorithm that predicts an answer how
confident it is as kind of a baseline
that maybe could do some good and we
found that it actually can do reasonable
but then we look at the algorithms we
trained designed for this task and we
see we get better
movement better performance and then
better performance from the handcrafted
method okay so cool we have algorithms
at work you might wonder why are they
working what's so predictive in the
nature of the data that allows us to
know whether a crowd will agree or offer
different answers and so we just
highlighted some examples where there's
strong disagreement and strong agreement
and the general conclusion we came to is
that the way the question was asked the
language is currently the most
productive and there's quite a bit more
analysis in the paper talking about this
idea so cool we have this way to predict
if people will agree or offer different
answers so we said then now let's try to
use this to think about how do we more
efficiently collect answers from a crowd
so the idea is that when we know that
people are going to all give the same
answer we want to collect one example we
want to ask one crowd worker to do the
work when we know that the crowd wall
for different answers we want to ask
many people in the crowd to give an
answer so that's the idea and that's
exactly what we did again the algorithms
we trained offer not only a prediction
of whether there'll be agreement or
answer differences but also a confidence
score in the belief that there will be
agreement or differences so we were able
to just rank all the visual questions in
a given batch of images and look at our
human budget and say we will allocate
only the extra budget where we collect
redundant examples to the cases where we
most confidently believe there's going
to be answer differences from a crowd so
that was the idea of what we did so
looking at some results this here shows
some plots for one of the data sets we
looked at results are similar on both of
the data sets we tested it shows what
happens when we don't collect any
redundant answers so one example for
every single visual question in the data
set gets you just above 60% performance
and getting the diversity of all
plausible answers that are available for
all those set of
questions 100% is where every single
visual question we collect five answers
per visual question and look at how many
of the unique answers are in the final
set get above 90% and in between is
where we decide which examples get one
versus five key take-home point is by
using this approach we were able to
accelerate capturing diversity by 23%
compared to if you use the baseline
bhisma's system that was being used by
people to collect three answers per
visual question in general that
translates to eliminating over eleven
forty hour work weeks in saving eighteen
hundred dollars with a very low pay so
we also explored a subsequent piece
where we noted that we can get further
performance gains if we figure out
exactly how many answers we should be
collected so we explored should we
collect one two all the way up to five
showing this with an example where you
can see there's one example answers to
exams answers and then more we would
want to click to exactly one to four or
ten so we did do some follow-up work on
that and we found that yes we can do
better in figuring out how to use a
human budget to get all the unique
answers okay so um next thing we
explored is we said okay that's great
but we don't really understand why
there's differences we're getting all
the plausible answers but do we really
want to do that so the next question we
explore it is learning to the next
problem we explore it is learning to
anticipate why a crowd will answer a
visual question differently and that can
be helpful in supporting users to
resolve answer differences okay
so motivation again we have three
examples here
when does this expire does this picture
look scary which side of the room is the
toilet on what's interesting is the
reason that there are differences is
different for each example okay so the
first one is the answers are all
accurate they're all fine
they're just synonyms second one
subjectivity we heard earlier talk about
this and then the last one is ambiguity
we're all our viable
reasons okay we did a literature survey
to try to figure out what are people
saying are the reasons why crowds differ
in providing answers and we also looked
at our data set and we came up with the
following categories of reasons for
possible answer difference so everything
from synonymous answers to subjectivity
to ambiguity which we talked about spam
of course as part of my answers differ
sometimes if you have a blind person the
evidence is not in the image for you
can't find the answer in the image
sometimes it's just really hard if you
need to find someone who has the domain
expertise sometimes the quality of the
data is so poor that it's not it's
difficult to find the information
sometimes the question is just invalid
it's not a question and sometimes people
offer different levels of granularity
and why they're given an answer so what
book is this someone might just say
Maxie AIDS someone might say Maxie aids
with some of the subtext underneath it
so given that we said here's a taxonomy
of reasons we had we looked at visual
questions from two different data sets
one from real people who are blind one
that was curated but is kind of the most
popular data set in the machine learning
community for a visual question
answering and we looked at the examples
where the ten answers do not match and
we collected labels from crowd workers
on what were their reasons for their
differences in the answers for all the
visual questions and what we found
looking at the two data sets as well as
looking at them combined you can see on
the x-axis each of the reasons the
y-axis is what percentage of visual
questions were classified as having that
reason for a disagreement we found that
approximately 20% of the answer
differences arise because of the
question image pair alone what that
means is that the question image pair
could be modified in order to arrive at
a single valid answer
the most common reasons for answer
differences were ambiguity synonymous
answers and varying love levels of
answer granularity interestingly the
least common reason is spam and it was
at about 1% for both datasets more of
our just note though trends were similar
both on the data from the real users of
a visual question answering system so
for people who are blind as well as from
that fake data set so that suggests that
even these fake toy datasets are
valuable to see trends in the real world
we then created a system system takes in
an image and a question goes through
some deep learning mechanisms and
outputs what are going to be the reasons
for answers to differ if any at all key
idea is we took a system that predicts
answers and the idea was that these
systems that are trying to figure out
how to give an answer already are
learning some idea of when insert
differences are going to rise built the
system evaluated it did it overall as
well as for each of the different
categories and what we found is that
overall when we compare our method the
bottom the first three are some
baselines next one is predicting from
the image alone question alone question
plus image question plus image plus
answers that are predicted and so on and
overall we see the method does quite
better for compared to the baselines
we also found promising results and the
ability to detect when a person could
either take the image again or ask the
question again so this is something that
means that a person who is blind with a
phone can snap a picture again instead
of having to wait 17 seconds to learn
from a remote person that there was a
problem right in terms of cases where
the algorithm does not do well well it's
typically for difficult or subjective
visual questions
not entirely surprising because these
are more abstract concepts and so
thinking about how do we embed common
sense into algorithms it's an important
next step so just taking a step back why
could this be useful one of course is
for some of the categories you can tell
the person asking the visual question
how to modify the visual question you
could also decide when to recruit more
costly experts you could also figure out
from the many aggregation schemes out
there that try to figure out from a
collection of responses from a crowd
which to deliver we could figure out
which scheme to employ and also in the
space of designing algorithms we can
rethink how we do a valuation for
algorithms in the case of evaluation
when you're looking at synonyms every
answer should be right same with
subjective and ambiguous every answer
should be right so that wraps up some of
the work that my group has been doing
there are a number of people here to
acknowledge as well as funding from NSF
for this work and just to summarize so
we found that a crowds answers do often
differ in fact it's about half the time
for the datasets we looked at we talked
about some novel problems and algorithms
for predicting when to what extent and
why answers will differ and also
suggested that it's possible to collect
the diversity of plausible answers more
efficiently I would like to leave you
with the idea that this is just a case
study what we are seeing here is not
just true for visual question answering
I believe it's going to be true for many
other problems we're exploring as a
community and I hope we all can start to
think about these answer differences and
automatically providing feedback to
people about why they will arise so
thank you
[Applause]
we have time for a few questions before
the break hi this is really fascinating
research and one question I have it
seems like it's kind of the Q & A like a
lot of discussion about it the answer
aspect like like predicting when and why
the answer would have a divergency I'm
kind of curious if through the research
or through the findings so far whether
you have some thought about like future
work in terms of helping the people with
visual impairment to better construct
their questions or like having the
machine in a way to like giving them
like initial feedback like waste for
them before you know send them out of
the question great question so we are
actually working on that part of it I
believe so part of it is just defining
the problem which is what we try to do
part of it is coming up with automated
solutions to help not only identify the
problem for us as researchers but inform
users of systems and then I think a lot
of it is also an HCI problem so you know
one of the things that you saw is our
current algorithms can do a good job but
they're not perfect so how will users
feel if we make them over and over take
new images as an example or keep re
asking the question if we don't have
perfect Excel gorillas what is the level
of performance we need from an algorithm
to make it useful for an end user also
figuring out how to help a use for a
user gracefully is important so you know
how do you tell someone that the
pictures poor quality and help the
person figure out how to take a higher
quality image or teaching someone how to
ask questions that aren't ambiguous I
mean I have that problem my daily life
right I asked a question and someone
doesn't give the answer I'm thinking of
and so I think there's also just a lot
of HCI
considerations to take in and then I
think within the theme of what we are
seeing today about human hayai
collaboration some of the some sometimes
we find that the tests are easy and can
actually be done by algorithm so
figuring out how to take those easy
examples and send it off to in theory
cheaper algorithms versus deciding to go
to more costly crowd workers versus
going to experts so these kind of hybrid
system designs for actually getting that
responses I saw a question around I
guess you could put this under the
banner like how do we not see proof are
like AI collaborative kinds of systems
so you're working in the context where
it's like everyone's acting in very good
faith and you're making decisions about
how to sort of allocate this labor and
you've got different kinds of tasks but
like imagine the context where you have
your your algorithms like sending work
out to a crowd and that crowds been
compromised
we're infiltrated are you're working at
a task where you're you're making
decisions about medical or judicial
decisions that like the crowd is making
for some reason when you think about
building these kinds of hybrid systems
like how do we sort of harden or have
have you have you thought about how we
harden our like AI maybe this is a
question for Cori - how do we think
about hardening these systems from sorts
of malicious actors yes that's an
interesting question and it's something
I think about because a line of work
that goes on my research group is
actually taking images and synthesizing
new fake content and images for good
purposes but it could be used for bad
purposes so yes I think about it I might
- I'm trying to think if I want to punt
til we're in the group session versus
answer that now cuz it's a very good
question maybe I'll just take a quick
kick it out now and we'll revisit that
as a panel so we know because we as a
community are learning how to develop
fake content in corrupted content we can
actually make algorithms that can start
to detect that so that means we need to
be aware of the fact that this is a
possible situation
and also have algorithms that are
notifying us about the quality of our
data so I think it's something extra
that is not one of the categories here
but we would hope to see an algorithm
that is doing a review of whether or not
there's some malicious attempt and we
can know from alteration we can look for
trends you know there's patterns in
corruption thank you for the question so
kind of slightly different than the
reasons are you also looking at actions
that would resolve things so in the case
of like the one picture of something
that you put up that was in a bag I
wasn't quite certain what it was and as
a human like if you were showing me
video I would say can you shift it a bit
can you show me the back right but
things that would cause you to change
the image and even if we could get
algorithms to generate those kind of
things yes I'm not certain what this is
but give me a different perspective on
it can be useful guidance for someone
that they can respond to are you also
looking at this kind of like taking
action to resolve my uncertainty yes so
we are just writing - this actually
relates to the response I had for an
earlier question and the answer is yes
we are starting to explore that I think
that we are sorry to score it I hope
with us releasing the data set others
will explore it - because I think this
is not a trivial problem this is this
has human factors involved this takes
you know it's a it's a collaboration
between people who are developing
algorithms people are developing mobile
phone applications and people are doing
human subject studies and I think it
really takes a large team to explore it
so we are doing that we actually have
collaboration with Microsoft that's
starting to think about some of this
work and all the data will be provided
freely so that others can also take this
up and do more work so no does that
answer your question or yeah okay
so seems like such a fertile space for
exploring all different ways of kind of
configuring humans and machines I think
that's what's so fun in general you know
about this kind of work that many of us
are doing and so you know it so so the
the idea that came to mind I wanted to
ask you have you looked at computer
mediated collaboration as a way to
resolve some of these differences you
know so I don't know if you know the ESP
game yeah
so some that that allows people to kind
of asymptote toward a common view you
know have a real-time which also
incentivizes the participation because
it's kind of a game it's fun to do
something like that yes so I agree that
that's a really exciting fertile space
actually I think that AJ's work earlier
where she talked about revolt is a
starting step in that direction if
that's the right paper I'm thinking of
so there are just little seeds of this
kind of work emerging yes
I have thought about it yes I would love
to do it the work has not been done so
right so there there there are a hundred
ways to slice and dice it and then
picking which one to pursue and also
having the tools that make it easy you
know both to sort of aggregate these
methods you know enact them within a
system make them reusable and then you
know each of us can can sort of we
develop a taxonomy of these things and
then it's not like we're brainstorming
de novo every time we have a new system
well you know how should we combine the
machines and the humans we start to
develop a sense of this is that you know
these are the classes of ways we can
combine these things and and and kind of
come together as a community to to sort
of formalize that stuff and make it
easier to move forward yeah and I think
a lot of that is gonna be a lot of
benchmarking and brute force work to
understand where do you out gorillas do
well where do humans do well this was
the last talk the point of really
understanding the strengths and the
weaknesses of the characters but I also
I think it's also very context dependent
so you know where the humans are sir
and the machines are strong in one
context could be upside down in a
different context depending right so I
mean it's just it's it's a it's a such a
complicated space good luck to all of us
with that so we'll meet again at 10:30
okay